字幕: Yuki Solomon
校正: Hiroko Kawano
河本真と申します
今日はコネクションということでですね
繋がる 繋がりについて
少しばかり皆さんと 考える時間を
取れればなということで
お話させていただきます
今 僕たち日本人の中で
何が起きているのかというと
バランスっていうものがすごく
失われているような気がしています
僕自身仕事上 今まで数千人の
人たちの相談に乗ってきました
その中で感じたのは
やはり皆さん 本来自分が求めない
過剰なものまでを求めるような
そういう時代になっているんじゃないかな
ということに気付きました
それには 先ほどお話しさせて
いただいたように
スマートフォンだったり
インターネットの発達によって
僕たちが 自分が本来求めていないこと
そういったものまでを無理に求めてしまう
これによって何が起きるかというと
僕たちが自分が本来求めていない
自分とは全く異なることをしてしまったり
そういったものを求めて
生きるようになってしまっています
これによって今 日本では
原因不明の病気であったり
そういった精神疾患だったりが
非常に増えてきています
そこで 僕自身が今
大事になってくると感じているのが
このバランスの取れた生き方
これが非常にこれからの時代に大事に
なってくるんじゃないかなということで
今日皆さんにお話しさせていただきます
まとめるとですね
繋がること —
自分と繋がり そして家族と繋がり
世界と繋がっていくことによって
バランスの取れた生き方ができる
バランスの取れた生き方が
できることによって
結果的に人様の 世の中のためになってしまう
そういった生き方が
できるんじゃないかなということで
今日はお話ししたいと思っております
自分と繋がるとは どういうことなのか？
それはですね
自分でアイデアを出して それによって
現実に変化が起こせる状態だと
僕自身は定義しています
僕たち — 僕自身もそうでしたけれども —
多くの人は日本の教育課程で
18歳までは自分自身で物事を決めたり
自分自身で何かをしていくことっていうのは
ほとんどありません
多くの方が 大体は
ご両親に言われたこと、先生に言われたこと
偉い人に言われたことを基準に
僕たちは常に行動を決めたり
自分でアイデアを出したり
そういうふうにして日々を過ごしています
しかし 僕たちが自分と繋がるために
必要なのは正解ではなく
常に自分自身が問いを持って動く
時には直感に身を任せて動く力が
必要だというふうに思っています
自分と繋がること —
言い換えると 自分に
自信を持つことになります
["頭"ではなくまず"身体"を動かせ!!]
はい 次ですね
自分と繋がるためにはどうするのかと
いうことなんですけれども
頭ではなく身体を動かせ —
こういったことになってくると思います
僕たちは先ほどお話しさせていただいたように
スマートフォンだったり
テクノロジーによってですね
いろんな情報を得て それをもとに
自分自身がすべきことだったり
アイデアだったりとか
毎日そういうことを決めています
しかし そういうことっていうのは
基本的には 頭を使って
考えていることなんですね
で 大事なのは僕たちが
身体を使って何かをしていく
それによって
自分自身の中から出てくるものを
実現することによって
自分と繋がっていくことが
できるんじゃないかなと思っております
これは皆さん ちょっと
笑うとこだったんですけれども
僕自身の１歳の時の写真です
（笑）
子どもの時って
皆さんプルプルしていて
生き方がすごく柔らかいんですよね
自分自身が興味あること 好奇心に応じて
どんどんどんどん生きている
頭で考えていないんですよ 子どもって
自分が興味があって これ面白いな
やってみようかなと思うことを
常に追っかけて
そういったことを常に自分自身の
毎日の中でやっていっているわけですね
だから彼らの動きはすごく柔らかいですし
すごく自然体なんですよ
ここで皆さんに一度是非 やっていただきたい
エクササイズがあります
こちら見ていただくと
書いてあるんですけれども
今これをやったら絶対に自分の未来に
インパクトが起きるアイデアは何だろうか？
これを是非 皆さんメモしていただいて
少しばかり考えてみてください
僕達は実は 自分自身で
何かやりたいこと アイデア —
これをやっていったら 自分の人生最高に
なりそうだということを皆さんお持ちです
ですけれども 毎日色々な
情報を収集したりとか
いろんな人の意見を
聞きすぎたりしてしまって
そういった部分の声に
従えなくなってしまっています
なので 僕自身が是非お勧めするのが
今 ご自身の人生の中で
こういうことをやっていったら
もっと自分の人生が
良くなっていくんじゃないか
ご機嫌になっていくんじゃないか
未来はさらにハッピーに
なっていくんじゃないか
こういったことを定期的に自身に問いてみる
これが僕自身 非常に大事になってくるんじゃ
ないかなというふうに思っております
で まさに僕自身が大学生の時に
やったプロジェクトです
ミクシィで会いたい人に
会ってみるプロジェクトっていうのを
僕自身 立ち上げました
立ち上げた時は 僕自身
一人でやっているんですけれども
「大学生だからできることって何なのかな？」
当時18歳だった僕自身は 一生懸命考えました
大学生だからこそできることを
いろいろ考えた結果
自分自身が普段会えないような人に
大学生っていう肩書を使って会っていくことが
実はできるんじゃないかなということで
いろんな人にアポイントメントを取って
いろんな人たちと会って
いろんな人たちと話して
彼ら[から]吸収をして
時には 彼らに怒られたりとか
「そんなふざけたこと言うな」というふうに
色々怒られたりしたんですけれども
そういったことをやっていました
これによって僕自身得られたものは
今まで 自分自身の行動基準
やることっていうのを
自分の親だったりとか 偉い人だったりとか
ある意味 国だったりとか
そうったものに決められてたことから
自分自身で何か自分で考えて
自分で感じて 自分で動いていく —
主体的に動いていく人生に変わってきました
これによって 僕自身は自信という
人生にとって とっても大事なものを
手に入れることができました
今の 自分と繋がれるっていうことを
まとめると この３つになります
まず１つ目に 自分自身に自信が付きます
そして２つ目に 自分の才能が分かります
自分でアイデアを出して行なっていく
自分で考えて行動していく
これによって
いろんな人たちとの関係ができたり
ある意味 自分の行動が故に失敗もします
そんな中から 色々学んだり
自分で感じたりすることで
自分の才能が分かってきます
今まで 自分では考えなかったこと
自分では思いつきもしなかったことを
自分で行なっていく
これによって 現実に結果が起きてきます
その結果を見て また何か色々学んで
その中から
自分のうまくいったこと すごく良かったこと
これをたくさんフィードバック
してもらっていくことによって
自分自身の才能っていうのが
分かってくるのかなというふうに
僕自身は思っております
そして３つ目 人生設計が
うまくなっていきます
自分自身で主体的にアイデアを出して
自分自身で行動を行なっていくことによって
自分自身の人生を自分で作っていける
そういった技術 そういった生き方に
少しずつシフトしていくんじゃないかな
というふうに思っております
まず１つ目に 自分と繋がるということを
お話しさせていただきました
次ですね 大事な人と繋がるということですね
次のステップに移っていきたいなと
いうふうに思っております
次はこちらですね
愛と癒しの充電スポットを
作ろうということでですね
まず自信を付けていった後に
次に僕たちが目指すべきステージ —
ステップを少しばかり
お話しさせていただきます
もしかしたらこれは
非常に今の日本にとっては
大事なテーマなのかもしれません
こちら
僕らが常に気になってしまうのは
常に他人のことばかりだ
僕自身も 昔そうでした
自分自身のことを気にするよりも
人からどう思われているか
自分自身が何かする時に
嫌われるんじゃないかな
馬鹿にされるんじゃないかな
失敗した時に「お前できないよ」と
言われるんじゃないかな
そういうことをずっと考えていました
ですけれども こういう状態だと
なかなか僕たち 折角
この一度きりしかない人生を
楽しむことっていうのは
できないわけですよね
僕が この繋がる技術に関して
繋がることに関して考えたのは
2011年の1月です
これはですね 僕自身の父親が
脳出血でこの月に倒れました
僕自身すごくショックでした
自分の大好きな父親が
今までとは違った光景になってしまう
そういった瞬間を 目の当たりにしました
この時僕自身が一つ感じたことが
自分の母親っていうものを
初めて一人の人間として
一人の人物として
初めて見ることができました
今まで自分のお母さんという
フィルターを通して
自分の母親のことを見ていました
なんですけれども
自分の父親が倒れたことによって
自分の母親が 初めて
一人のお母さんに見えました
一人の人間に見えました
今までお母さんには
一切心配とか不安ごととか
そういったものがないと
僕自身は思っていたんですけれども
この事件を通して
僕自身は お母さんにもたくさんの
寂しさや不安や恐怖がある
そういったことを
初めて気づくことができました
この経験から
僕自身は 自分自身が母親に対して
できることは何なのか
これを徹底的に考えるようになり
お母さんと一緒に向き合って
お母さんと一緒に話して
共に泣き 共に笑い 共に楽しむと
いうことを決意して
コミュニケーションを取るようになりました
[（英語）家族]
その結果 僕自身は今まで
何かを過剰に求めたり
何かを自分自身が求めてないものを目指して
送ってきた人生をやめることになって
自分自身がいつでも何でも相談できる —
そういった場所を手に入れることができました
結果的に僕自身には
生命エネルギーがたくさん溢れて
常に実家に帰った時に
愛とエネルギーを得られる
そういった場所を家族という形で
作ることができました
これは僕自身が父親に書いたメッセージです
一緒にいるだけが家族ではない
どこにいようが どれだけお互いを
思えるかが本当の家族なんだ
僕自身 この時に初めて本当の意味での
家族ということが分かりました
エクササイズの２を
ご紹介させていただきます
とは言っても 皆さん なかなか普段
身近にいる家族だったり
大事な恋人だったり 自分の大好きな人と
なかなか本音で話す機会 本音で話せるような
機会というのは減っていると思います
そんな中で 僕自身が人と仲良くなる時に
人と一線を超える関係になる時に
行なっているワークがこちらです
まず 「ありがとう」
これを10個書き出してみてください
そして次に 「ごめんなさい」
そして３つ目に「愛しています」
これを10個書き出してみてください
これは「ホ・オポノポノの法則」といって
ハワイの先住民の人たちが治療用に開発した
そういった言葉なんですけれども
ぜひこれをですね 自分の大事な人だったり
家族だったりとか 自分の愛している人に
ぜひ一度書き出して伝えてみてください
僕自身も去年の妻の誕生日に
これをやってみました
普段なかなか「ありがとう」って
言えないです 僕たちは
なかなか「ごめんなさい」って言えないです
なかなか「愛してます」って言えないです
でも 誕生日とか そういった記念日の機会に
こういったことをですね
書いてやってみるんですね
そうすると ものすごく深い繋がりを感じます
温かい時間を過ごせます
普段言えなかったことを
二人で話せるようになります
これによって 僕たちの中に
自分自身が心の底から安心できる
そういった場所ができるようになります
僕たちの人生 スマートフォンが
充電器によってフルに常に使えるように
僕たちの人生にもそういった充電場所が
僕自身は必要だと思っています
男の人は外に働きに行く
最近では女性も働きに行くような
社会になってきています
そして 会社で怒られたりとか
学校で怒られていく
そして最近では家に帰っても
怒られている人たちが増えています
しかし僕自身 家族というのは
ある意味 充電器のような場所
充電できるような場所として
捉えていくことが非常に大事だと思いますし
こういった場所があるからこそ
僕たちは 日々いろんなことに
チャレンジしたり
いろんなことに取り組めたりするんでは
ないかなというふうに思っております
僕自身がこのコミュニケーションを通して
昔こんなみかんみたいな顔を
してたんですけれども
皆さん笑うとこですよ
（笑）
この結果 こんな風にカッコ良くなりました
これはですね 僕自身が瞑想をしていて —
僕の子どもが [僕が]瞑想していると
いつも僕をいじめに来るんですけれども —
こういう状態になることができました
[世界と繋がる]
次にですね 世界と繋がる
こちらが最後のステージになります
自分と繋がって 自分自身に自信が付いて
そして大事な人と繋がって
常に充電ができる
自分自身が愛情を感じる場所ができた
そしてその後に
初めて世界と繋がっていくことで
自分自身が世界に対して
世の中に対してできることが
僕自身は自然に見えてくると思います
僕自身は大学生の時にずっと悩んでいました
自分の使命とは何なのか
自分自身が人生を通して
本当にやり遂げたいことは何なのか
ずっと考えていました
しかし 分かりませんでした
そして 僕自身それは一度忘れて
先ほどのステップ
まず 自分自身が自分でアイデアを出して
自分と繋がっていくこと
そして次に 自分の家族
まず自分の家族としっかり繋がって
自分自身の家族が幸せに そしてハッピーに
生きられるようなことをしていくこと
このステップを終わった段階で
次こっちのステップに行くことによって
自分がやるべきこと
自分が人生を通して世の中に対して
できることっていうのが分かりました
自分自身が自分自身にとって
大事な存在であるということ
自分自身が 自分のアイデアを信じられて
常に行動できるようになって
そしてお家に帰ったら 常に充電できる
そして愛情を感じられる場所ができた時に
初めてこの段階で僕自身は
世の中のことをフラットに
そして全力で楽しめるんじゃないかな
というふうに思ってます
今まで 僕たちの人生
もしかしたら 誰かの言葉が常に気になったり
何かが気になって
なかなか現実を楽しめなかったり
エンジョイできなかった人もいると思います
しかし自分と繋がり 家族と繋がれることで
改めて世界っていうものをありのままに
そのままの角度で見ることができるんじゃ
ないかなというふうに思っております
そこで僕自身が
自分の経験から分かったことが
世界に出ることは ＝（イコール）
違いを味わうことです
違いを味わう 見ること
そういった意味で 最近では
海外の方も日本に来たりとか
日本人の方も海外に
たくさん行けるようになって
色々な物を見られるような時代に
なってきたと思うんですけれども
その中で色々な違いを見たり
色々な物を見たりしていく中で
何が起きるかっていうと
自分自身が本当にできることが
分かってきます
なかなか僕たちは同じようなものとか
常に同じものに触れていると
自分ができることとか 自分自身に対して
気付くことはないです
ですけれども いろんな物を見たり
いろんな物を感じたりすることによって
自分が本当にできること
自分がやるべきことっていうのが
どんどん自然に分かってくるんじゃ
ないかなというふうに思っています
今回は皆さんにお伝えしたいことは
３つだけです
自分と繋がり そして家族と繋がり
世界と繋がっていく
これが非常に大事になってくる
そして その世界と繋がることで初めて
自分自身ができることが
自分自身が世界に対して この人生を
通してやりたいことが見えてくる
それができるんじゃないかなと思っております
そういう訳でですね
今日はこの３つのお話をさせていただきました
ぜひですね まず —
繰り返しになるんですけれども —
まず みなさん 自分自身のアイデアを
信じて行なってみる
それによって主体的な生き方に変わって
自分に自信が付いてきます
自分に自信が付くということは
ある意味自分で悩まなくなります
そして 自分で悩まなくなった時に
自分の大事な人だったり
自分の家族と そして自分の仲間と
しっかり繋がってください
繋がるということはある意味
一線を超えることなので
時には傷付いたりとか 悲しんだりとか
涙を流すこともあると思います
でもそれを恐れずに一線を超えることで
いつでも常に繋がれる
自分が不安だった時 恐怖を感じた時は
相談ができたりとか
自分自身が嬉しかった時は
喜びを分かち合ったりとか
そういった場所ができます
そういった本当の意味での
繋がりができることによって
改めて 世界というもの
この地球というものを
ありのままに フィルターを通さず
見えるようになります
頭の中が常にクリアになった状況で
また世界を見ていく
冒険をしていくことによって
自分自身がこの人生を通して
やりたいこと やるべきこと
自分が世の中に対してできること
こういうのが 自然に見えてくると思ってます
ですので是非 皆さんと一緒に
これからも自分自身と繋がり
そして大事な人と繋がり
そして世界と繋がっていく
こういった生き方が共有できれば
良いのかなというふうに思っております
今日はご静聴ありがとうございました
（拍手）